In and out in and out.
Staying alive is about doing things this very second,
your cells are combusting glucose molecules with oxygen to make energy
available,
which keeps you alive for another precious moment to get the oxygen
to your cells. You'll breathing.
Breathing is an answer to a very hard problem.
How do you get the resources that your cells need to survive from the outside
to the inside of your cells? Every living thing has to solve this problem.
And the solution is surprisingly different depending on one of the most
important regulators of life size,
as we've discussed in other videos of different scales,
the physical laws of the universe have different consequences for its
inhabitants. Simple things like temperature, micro gravity,
or surface tension might not matter to you or be a deadly danger,
depending on how big you are. Living.
Things need a lot of different materials to keep themselves going and they
somehow need to transport them from the outside to the inside.
This was a huge problem for the first things on the verge of being alive,
because doing anything in our universe requires energy.
And the first living beings on earth did not have the abundance of tools and
techniques available that life has today after billions of years of evolution.
So at the very beginning life needed to find a way to get good stuff
inside and bad stuff outside of itself without using energy.
Luckily, the very first forms of life were very,
very small and because they were so small,
they were able to use a free form of transport.
That was based on a physical law called diffusion.
Diffusion is the rule of the universe that molecules,
especially in liquids or gases are constantly moving around in all
directions.
And because they move around and bump into each other and other molecules,
they tend to spread. For example, if you drop a sugar cube into water,
then there is a lot of sugar in one place.
And in another place there's none as sugar molecules dissolve in the
water.
They will start randomly bumping against the water molecules and other sugar
molecules slowly,
all the sugar molecules will spread out and form multiple phases of different
concentrations.
These random movements continue endlessly until at some point the sugar will be
spread evenly in the water.
The great thing about diffusion is that life can use it for free.
It doesn't require energy and life loves free things.
So all life on earth relies on diffusion.
Let's look at the smallest living, being on earth,
a bacterium specifically its surfaces cell
membranes allow for diffusion of certain molecules.
This specific bacterium consumes oxygen to live while carbon dioxide is
produced inside as a waste product. So inside the bacterium,
there isn't a lot of oxygen,
but a lot of carbon dioxide because of diffusion,
these molecules will eventually spread evenly.
So the carbon dioxide diffuses out while oxygen is constantly replenished
from the outside,
but this kind of breathing only works for the very small world for
bacteria or amoeba or your cells, and a few very small animals.
Insects, for example,
have a fine network of trickier tunnels with a pressure gradient where AV very
slowly can diffuse in and exchange gases with the insect cells.
But even insects seem to be able to contract that truck here. And at least some,
even half specialized breathing organs like spiracles and ASACs
that certain scales diffusion is just too slow to keep cells alive.
The fundamental problem is that the exchange with the environment can only
happen at the surface and diffusion of materials can only sustain a
certain amount of insight.
Tiny living things have only a little bit of inside or volume
and a lot of outside or surface area.
But what if we wanted to create a bacteria,
the size of a blue whale and had a very convenient enlargement machine,
we would sadly be messed up by the square cube law. In a nutshell,
it means that if you make something 10 times larger it's outside or surface
would grow by 100,
but its insides or volume grows by 1000 times.
If we compare the bacterium pseudomonas original. So with a blue whale,
we see that the bacterium has 10 million times more surface in relation
to its volume than the whale.
The bacterium has a lot of outsides while the whale has a lot of insights.
If we make a bacterium, the size of a whale,
our giant bacteria now has too much inside.
And most of it's inside is now very far from its surface.
The oxygen our bacteria needs would never reach the inside before it would run
out of oxygen. Our giant bacterium would just die.
Still being bigger,
has many upsides from making it harder to be eaten,
to making it easier to eat others.
But the size of cells is limited by the distance oxygen and nutrients can
affectively diffuse to provide the inside with enough resources.
So life avoided this problem by forming of multicellular structures,
beings composed of many cells instead of one,
because diffusion works better. If you have many small units, instead of one,
much bigger one over time,
the cell buddies began to share work and specialize.
Some cells concentrated on sensing the environment, others on digestion,
others on movement, but that still wasn't enough.
The problem of diffusion and surface and energy production remained limiting the
size. These first multicellular forms of life could attain.
So in order to become even bigger knife solve the diffusion problem by having
holes and caves and tunnels and by folding in on itself.
So diffusion could happen easily in each one of the cells take
yourself. What you consider your outside.
Your skin has a surface area of about two square meters,
but your lungs have a surface area of about 70 square meters.
They aren't like balloons.
They're more like sponges filled with many tiny packs, tiny balloons,
surrounded by blood vessels.
When you breathe in all these tiny balloons, fill up with fresh air.
Blood filled out with CO2 is pumped around the balloons.
And then the magic of diffusion happens.
The oxygen diffuses into the blood where it's picked up by red blood cells
and the CO2 diffuses out of the blood and into your lungs where it can be
breathed out again. Your blood then carries oxygen,
rich blood into the furthest corners of your body and picks up the CO2 waste.
Diffusion in the body is effective at about one millimeter.
So every cell in your body is at most one millimeter away from a blood vessel.
So medium size animals.
Like you need a lot of blood vessels to reach every cell in the body.
Your body has around 100,000 kilometers of cup. Hillary's alone.
The tiniest of your blood vessels with a surface area of around 1000
square meters.
This is true for all parts of you that want to exchange something with the
outside world. Your body needs surfaces to take in nutrients from your food.
So your gut has the surface area of half a Babington called roughly 40 square
meters. The larger you are, the more hidden surfaces you need.
Take a tree it's way to stay alive is to create sugar out of thin air and
sunlight. So it needs as much surface area as possible.
An orange tree with 2000 leaves has a leaf surface area of 200
square meters.
But the surface inside the leaves where the fusion actually occurs is
6,000 square meters.
The same with roots where water diffuses from the soil into countless tiny hairs
that maximize the surface area,
the roots of one square meter of grass at up to around 350
square meters of surface.
If we look at the breathtaking diversity of life on this planet,
it seems like everything is pretty different and it is,
but some basic principles are the same for everybody and have not changed
significantly for billions of years. If we look at the very,
very small, all of the very,
very big waste goes out and fresh fuel comes in
big animals just need a lot of complex plumbing to make it possible.
Fresh fuel is something we can all use from time to time,
especially for our creativity audit ready takes is to try something new
and we have the perfect opportunity to get you started.
We partnered with Skillshare,
an online learning community that offers courses on almost any creative skill,
such as design illustration, animation, photography, and cooking.
They have thousands of courses starting from every level.
So wherever you are right now, there'll be something for you.
Maybe you want to look behind the scenes of our animations. For example,
we've made a couple of skills have courses that teach you how we animated scenes
from our videos with video lessons, classes and hands-on projects,
or if you'd rather look into illustration first,
we recommend Adobe illustrator level up your colors by Hayden obey.
But what you pick first doesn't really matter that much.
The important part is to get started, have some fun and get new inspiration.
Unlimited access to all classes is only $10 a month with an annual premium
membership.
And the first 1000 cuts exempt viewers to click the link in the description,
get a special treat. You'll get a free trial of Skillshare premium.
If you want to break out of your rut by exploring a new skill and support cuts,
cause I'd give it a try and we have something else to make your learning
experience truly perfect. Our new ocean Explorer notebook.
It has beautiful sparkly, full lettering,
and for at his infographic pages inside taking you on a journey under the sea,
the perfect companion for all your note, taking needs,
designed and produced with love weather [inaudible] thank you for
watching.